مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
اذا ونرحب باللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ونبدا مع محمود الكن
يفترض الان بدات المرحله الثالثه محمود من
الناحيه العسكريه نعم عثمان هذه المرحله
ما تزال الانتقال اليها هو بشكل تدريجي
كما نشاهد من التصريحات لكن بدات تبرز
العمليات على على الاقل في شمال قطاع غزه
دعونا نشاهد هذه الخريطه الان هنا كامل
قطاع غزه اللون الاصفر هو لحركه المناوره
البريه اللون الازرق هي للمناطق العسكريه
المغلقه اسرائيليا في غلاف غزه الان في
المناطق الشماليه التكتيك العسكري لهذا
اليوم ان تحول الى استهداف بالطيران مكثف
بحسب ما ذكره
مراسلونا طوال هذا اليوم نحن نتحدث عن
استهداف
بالطيران كان لهذه المناطق في بيت حانون
بيت لاهيا في جباليا ايضا في المناطق
الجنوبيه التي كان فيها التوغل سابقا من
الجنوب الشرقي حتى الجنوب الوسط والجنوب
الغربي الان ايضا كذلك كان هناك استهداف
لوسط مدينه غزه هذا الاستهداف ياتي
بالتزامن مع ذكر الجيش جيش الاحتلال بانه
تم سحب لواء من شمال غزه ما هي هذه
الالويه حسب المعهد ال الراسات
الاستراتيجيه سنشاهد هنا هذه ال هذا هذه
الخريطه لكامل قطاع غزه هنا كان ثلاثه
الويه تعمل في الشمال لكن الوضع تغير
اليوم انسحب هذا اللواء اللواء الخامس نحن
نتحدث عن لواء مشات وكان من الويه
الاحتياط بالتالي
وحسب معهد دراسات الحروب فان هناك لوائين
وكثير تعمل على الاقل حسب الدراسات
الماضيه اذا ما سحبنا منه وحدثنا الخبر
لهذا اليوم بالتالي تصبح مجموع الالويه
العامله في كامل قطاع غزه نتحدث عن لوائين
ثلاثه وخمسه اي اننا نتحدث بما مجموعه عره
الويه مجموع الالويه المنسحبه اذا ما
شاهدنا هنا سنشاهد بان الالويه التي
انسحبت هي تقريبا 11 لواء بالتالي 10
الويه فاعده في القطاع تقريبا
و1 لواء منسحبا هذه دراسات تقديريه ل حسب
ما كان قد ذكره معهد دراسات الحروب على
الاقل سابقا مركز استقل العمليات ما يزال
هو في جنوب قطاع غزه اذا ما اتجهنا الى
هنا مركز ثقل العمليات ما يزال في غرب
خانيونس وجنوب خانيونس اضافه الى الضغط من
الشمال لكن المقاومه ذكرت بانها كان كانت
قد استهدفت دبابات ميركافا في هذه المناطق
واستطاعت تدمير بعضها هذه هي ابرز
العمليات التي لدينا اليوم عثمان نعم
محمود سيده اللواء الان سحب هذا
اللواء ما الذي يه بالنسبه للوضع العسكري
هو تقريبا منذ ثلاثه اسابيع كان هناك
الحديث عن الدخول في المرحله الثالثه وتم
سحب الاليات الوحدات
كامله لفتره قدرت بحوالي عده ايام لكن
استمرت عمليات ال القسف وهناك مسببات من
وجهه نظر جيش الاحتلال متى تدخل القوات
ومتى تخرج هذه القوات وهذا مرتبط بظهور
مقاتلين وا الحصول على معلومات عن الانفاق
او عن الرهائن
في تلك الفتره تم اعاده بناء اي القدرات
القتاليه ل حماس وتم اعاده بناء القدره
على شكل لوائين من 12 كتيبه وبدات حركتهم
تظهر فوق الارض وكانت هي المقصود منها
حركه جاذبه لانه استمرار القصف كما تحدث
محمود في هذا اليوم القصف الجوي يطال كل
المناطق وبالتالي ما هي الاوراق القوه بيد
المقاومه لا اوراق قوه اذا كان قصف طيران
لانه الامكانات محدوده الامكانات الاساسيه
هي الاسلحه قصيره المدى ياسين تاندم وتي
بي جي والار بي جي فكانت تتم عمليه اظهار
القدرات حتى في بعد الاداره المدنيه ليس
فقط في البعد العسكري وهذا ما ازعج الجانب
الاسرائيلي فكانت عمليات التدخل وكانت من
مناطق مختلفه معظمها تدخل محدود سواء كانت
من الشمال او من الشيخ عجلين لكن حدث فقط
معركتين الرئيسيات في منطقه التفاح الدرج
وا وجباليا ومن ثم ان كفات هذه القوات
الان هذه المرحله الثالثه ماذا تعني تلخص
في جمله واحده عمليات جراحيه انتقائيه من
اجل تحقيق اهداف محدوده هذا الوضع في
الشمال الان سحب اللواء لانه يدور حديث
كثير هذه الالويه ارهقت الحق بها خسائر
وهناك تضارب حتى في المقاربات اين ستذهب
هل هناك اعاده بناء قوه وابقائها في هذه
المنطقه كاحتياط ام سترسل الى الشمال بعض
المواقع الاسرائيليه حدثت انه تم نقل لواء
جولاني كاملا واعادته لمنطقه الشماليه في
وهناك توجه لتعزيز القدرات القتاليه فيما
تقارير اخرى تقول العكس بالمطلق لا هناك
تخفيف من التواجد العسكري على الواجهه
الشماليه نعم يعني طبعا هو الفارق في
الامكانيات معروف ولن نعيده ولكن فبالتالي
كل الايام صعبه ولكن هذه المرحله الثالثه
الى اي مدى تشكل تحد للمقاومه المرحله
الثالثه الان نحن نتحدث عن القاطع الشمالي
فقط لا غير من شارع عشره شمالا الحدود
الشماليه لوادي غزه اما وادي غزه وال
منتصف القطاع
و خان يونس وحتى الحدود مع جمهوريه مصر
العربيه لا هذه هي المرحله الحقيقيه لم
يتم التحول لمرحله الثالثه لانه يوجد في
الوسط عندك ثلاثه الويه يوجد في الجنوب
خمسه الويه اربعه منها تحيط في مدينه خان
يونس اللي مساحتها 5 م مربع واللواء
الخامس هو موجود في على المنطقه الشرقيه
لانه المنطقه الشرقيه استعصت عليهم لم
يستطيعوا ان ان يدخلوا في عمقها بصوره
حقيقيه وبالتالي اذا تحدثنا عن المنطقه
الجنوبيه عبسال الكبرى عبسان الجديد بن
سيلا لم يستطيعوا ان يفعلوا الكثير منها
فبالتالي نقلت المعركه الى مدينه خانيونس
لجمله من الاعتبارات ان الصيد الثمين
موجود بها وما هو الصيد الثمين الرهائن
وقيادات الصف الاول يعني القراءه
الاسرائيليه تقول انهم موجود موجودين في
تلك المنطقه فالان المعركه الرئيسيه
الفعليه هي معركه خان يونس رغم وجود اربعه
الويه معظم هذه الالويه على الاطار
الخارجي باستثناء تم دفع لواء مظليين على
شكل قوات مشاه وهم قد يعرض بعض الافلام
التي تشير الى حركتهم في داخل مدينه خان
تتوقع الان ان القتال قد يشتد مؤكد لانه
الان
لاحظ مخيم خان يونس صغير جدا اقصى دخول
الى المخيم في هذا اليوم وصل الى عمق 200
متر بعد حوالي 10 ايام هذا يعطيك فكره عن
طبيعه المعركه وبالتالي ليس من السهول
الدخول والسيط كلمه السيطره مستبعده نتح
نتحدث عن الدخول كذلك صعب لانه علينا ان
ان نعقد مقارنه سريعه عن الشجاعيه مع
خانيونس عن التفاح مع خانيونس وبالتالي
كانوا يدخلوا ويجبر على الخروج وهذا ما
يجري في المعركه الحاليه وسيقتصر الامر
على عمليات انتقائيه جراحيه تعتقد ام
سيكون بقوه كا لا في الجنوب ليست عمليات
جراحيه في الجنوب حرب
مفتوحه يوجد اربعه الويه من الشمال من
منطقه القراره والزن ومن منطقه الغربيه
منطقه الحمد والى الجنوب منها من منطقه
المخيم ومن الجنوب الشرقي هناك معارك
ضاريه اسرائيل دفعت باربعه الويه من اجل
ان تدخل وتسيطر وبالتالي لا اتحدث عن
عمليات جراحيه اتحدث عن معركه معركه قسر
عظم ما بين المقاومه والجيش الاسرائيلي
جيش الاحتلال ما الذي سيكون التحدي الاكبر
بالنسبه لقوات الاحتلال الخسائر
التحدي الاكبر الخسائر ف فاتوره فاتوره
التكاليف وهل تتحمل فاتوره التكاليف من
اجل الوصول الى الصيد الثمين اذا كان
موجودا لانه غير مؤكد انه موجود هل هو
موجود في خان يونس موجود في رفح هل ذهب
الى القراره هل ذهب الى الشمال لانه شبكه
الانفاق
تغطي كافه خاصه شبكه الانفاق القتاليه
ممتده من بيت حانون حتى رفح اذا هم
قراءتهم انهم موجودين في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي هذ معركه كسر عظم وليست عمليه
جراحيه انتقائيه وبالمناسبه تم الاعلان عن
مقتل عشره ضباط اسرائيليين في الساعات ال4
الماضيه بل ليس مقتل اصيب اصيب ايضا ع
ضباط شكرا لواء فايز الدوي شكرا موصول
لمحمود الكن طبعا وختام هذه النافذه
العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل على غزه